oh but very quickly I have to say
another movie we loved you in was of
course knives out oh right that movie I
mean it just went gangbusters didn't hit
that movie yeah yeah I did well I mean
people love a good murder mystery and
it's one of those genres that I don't
think has been explored as much as maybe
some other genres in film so so I think
people were really excited about having
one done really well and as well as the
plot you know people loved the plot of
knives out they loved the characters but
they also loved the cable knit sweater
yeah yeah they did you know who doesn't
love a cable it's my favorite thing
about living in Massachusetts you get a
good six month window where a cable
networks but no people went mad for it
it turned into headline news everyone
went nuts of a Chris Evans knives out
sweater Chris heavens as a sweater is
getting people hot and bothered over
knitwear Esquire here's how you can get
Chris Evans verifies that presumably you
go to a shop that's my goal in my career
to try and let some sort of prop or an
animate object do the heavy lifting for
me and then take all the credit and
presumably you could never wear one
again you know III do get a little bit
of side eyes when I wear one now it's a
little bit of like nah guy he's wearing
a you know but but I figure a couple
years I can't stay away but someone in
your family can wear one how beautiful
does dog disguise I think I think he
doesn't like it no sleeves I think
[Music]
you